So what is InterPlanetary Project about? In a nutshell, it's understanding living
planets and their long-term prospects,
including their collapse. So it's not
just planets out there. It's our own, and
that's very important. It's the only one
that we know of that's living.
- My thought was that through interstellar travel
we'd be able to discover environments
that were like the Earth.
- I personally
doubt that terraforming other planets
works or makes sense unless people go
there with a sense of mission.
- I tend to agree with Neal that without
something like that, that's ennobling and
deeply motivating, it will be very
difficult to restrain the worst angels
of our nature.
- That's one of the
beautiful lenses right? That by focusing
on terraforming another planet, you have
to think very carefully about the
extraordinary failures of terraforming
our own planet.
- There might be two reasons for that
movement: one is pure discovery, and
madness, and the other one is just
desperation and need.
- If we're gonna have a project, the InterPlanetary Project, right?,
what should we design that recognizes
those limitations and that are not being
addressed by what we have currently?
- How does that, what you just articulated,
relate to whatever the concept is of
InterPlanetary?
- Everything about New
Mexico is why this particular topic is
so resonant to do here.
- What are we
trying to accomplish and why do we think
it's important?
- So I think we look at, you
know, starting this in Santa Fe but then
as we build and plan and think about
what this could mean, I mean we could
create dystopian societies throughout
New Mexico! (laughter)
The reason I originally came to New
Mexico because northern New Mexico was a
hotbed of communes and so on.
- What are we trying to accomplish and why do we think
it's important?
- I wouldn't mind transcending my humanity
and merging my mind with a greater
organism.
- Don't feel the need at any
point to map this on to any kind of
project you're familiar with.
- So if you
were to look forward I wonder what the
group would think of culmination of the
various things that are happening in the
world today from the technology point of
view, so robots, general artificial
intelligence, what's happening in
datasets in computing, etc., moving towards
another evolution of the human species
no longer being organic?
- It's very obvious that we're starting to tinker
with our genome and where that's going
to lead us is a major, major question.
- We should actually just see ourselves as
agents in a grand evolutionary history.
- Wouldn't it be wonderful to instill
the terror that an astronaut would feel
as they're escaping even the view of Earth? I mean, going to Mars and it just is
receding seems to me to be just
horrifying.
- The idea of going out is to
look in.
- I think it's also a place
where you can convince scientists that
there are relatively understudied and
interesting problems.
- The target there
will be starting with the whole planet,
actually, and projecting down locally.
- What are the things we could do
that would really make people
uncomfortable, get people angry, or get
people to come to Santa Fe to protest
what they thought this was about?
- Are you okay with that?
- I'm okay with anything this room does.
- Cuz Marky said InterPlanetary.
- Finally, it is a participatory project,
meaning that it produces things, so it's
not like Burning Man or Comicon, where
you go to enjoy yourself exclusively. Out
of it come films, out of it come books,
out of it come movements.
- That seems like dynamic territory, you know?